there are new questions about some of
the safety technology found in a rising
number of new cars automatic emergency
braking will be standard in most cars in
2022 it's expected to cut the number of
rear-end crashes in half but hundreds of
drivers say sometimes the system slams
on the brakes apparently for no reason
Kris Van Cleave is in Washington Kriss
that doesn't sound good good morning
well good morning the technology is
supposed to sense when a crash is
imminent alert the driver and if need be
hit the brakes but we found reports from
drivers claiming crashes even injuries
because of false activations of the
emergency braking systems on cars no car
makers and safety advocates say the vast
majority of the time the technology
works as it should but it is not perfect
do you worry every time you get in the
car now mm-hmm
for Cyndi Walsh just getting behind the
wheel of her 2018 Nissan Rogue raises
her anxiety level she says since she
bought the SUV new last October it has
slammed on the brakes three times for no
clear reason when she says there was no
risk of a collision first one I was
driving down a four-lane highway and
going about 55 and it completely came to
a complete stop how do you feel about
driving the car now I'm scared too I I
don't drive it Walsh took it to the
dealer each time twice she says they
told her they fixed it the National
Highway Traffic Safety Administration is
now investigating the 2017 and 2018
rogue after learning of nearly 850
complaints of false activation of the
SUV's automatic braking system that
includes reports of 14 crashes and five
injuries Jason Levine from the center
for auto safety you are just going along
the road and your car just stops the
rogue like about half of new cars sold
is equipped with forward collision
avoidance technology that includes
automatic emergency braking
it's supposed to sound an alarm and
automatically break if you're about to
rear-end another vehicle
it'll be standard in most cars within
three years people saying they were
turning it off the technology can help
and does save you and prevents crashes
but only if it's on and only if it's
working well obviously this mood George
our recall very quickly the Insurance
Institute for Highway Safety says auto
braking is making driving safe
estimating the technology could cut
rear-end collisions in half preventing
28,000 crashes and 12,000 injuries by
2025 these autonomous emergency braking
systems they are effective they are
working in the real world but there's
definitely room for improvement
since 2015 there have been seven recalls
for auto braking issues affecting nearly
180,000 vehicles there are more than
half a million Nissan Rogue subject to
the nitsa investigation and the
regulator has received hundreds of
complaints about so-called phantom
braking in vehicles from a number of
other automakers if I want to start the
autopilot what do I do it happened to us
last year I think overall it is safer
we were driving a Tesla Model 3 with
autopilot riding with us was seen at
Roadshow editor Tim Stevens the car
pumped the brakes as we approached an
overpass on a busy New Jersey freeway
may have actually seen that bridge as
another car and so another example that
all Paul's not perfect I was in a
statement Nissan acknowledges some rogue
drivers may experience false activation
on unique road conditions like some
railroad crossings bridges and
low-hanging traffic lights but says it
is committed to the safety and security
of our customers and has made a free
software update available at dealerships
Cindy Walsh is unconvinced I don't feel
safe driving it anymore I don't feel
safe put my family in it so I don't want
the car Walsh took Nissan to arbitration
she just won which means after she pays
for mileage she's going to be able to
give her vehicle back Tesla did not
respond to repeated requests for comment
car makers say this driver assistance
technology is preventing crashes every
day it's on the roads and it is getting
better the longer it's out there Tony
all right but one false activation as
they put it is yes Chris thank you very
much
roads do it when you're Nissan Rogue
goes rogue goes
very unfortunate name for that car it's
interesting there Tim and Chris say that
was odd that was disconcerting I would
say that was very scary because it
happen once you're convinced it can
happen again and again you gotta figure
that out all right Chris thank you very
much